ah
se calcula que en américa latina' avión
alrededor de 100 millones de mujeres
negras por eso cada 25 en julio se
conmemora el día internacional de la
mujer afrodescendiente en conmemoración
de la fundación de la red de mujeres
afrolatinoamericanas afrocaribeñas y de
la diáspora el 25 de julio en 1992 que
hoy en día reúne a lideresas de más de
21 países del continente americano
colombia hace parte de esta red con
mujeres que trabajan activamente por el
mejoramiento de la calidad de vida de la
población afrocolombiana y es que las
mujeres afro en colombia todavía
enfrentan una doble o hasta triple
discriminación enfrentar el machismo
también enfrentan el racismo y muchas
veces también el clasismo lo que lleva a
una intersección alidad que las ha
llevado también a ser parte del
movimiento feminista latinoamericano y
alcanzar cada vez más espacios de
representación en la participación
política en la creación de empresas en
el liderazgo social y comunitario cada
vez más mujeres negras hacen parte de
esa toma de decisiones que ha permitido
también aumentar la representación y la
representatividad y la participación de
las poblaciones negras en el país
[Música]
en panamá un estudio reciente del año
2020 del programa de naciones unidas
para el desarrollo reveló que las
mujeres afrodescendientes tienen el
triple de las condiciones adversas para
su crecimiento sufren discriminación por
su condición de mujer por su color de
piel y además por su condición económica
y aunque la realidad es distinta
dependiendo del entorno y es evidente
que las mujeres en situación de pobreza
o pobreza extrema tienen posibilidades
casi nulas del ascenso social por no
contar con educación de calidad de
acceso a servicios públicos adecuados
buenos salarios quienes son parte de la
clase media o alta manifiestan que deben
realizar un esfuerzo constante para
dejar clara sus capacidades y seo
liderazgos la discriminación a los
afrodescendientes en panamá existe según
este estudio pero según también las
propias las voceras de esta comunidad
que representa una cuarta parte de la
población del país en cuanto a los
avances las propias mujeres
afrodescendientes destacan a la creación
de diversos entes estatales creados para
promover no sólo los valores culturales
sino también para trabajar en pro de
políticas públicas de esta comunidad
[Música]
el 8% de la población costarricense es
afrodescendiente las mujeres que son más
de 160.000 viven discriminación por su
raza etnia y género recientemente la
vicepresidenta epsy campbell la primera
mujer afrodescendiente en llegar al
cargo destacó el reto de la estadística
en el país aun no hay datos que
visibilicen las afectaciones propias de
esta población por lo que el censo
poblacional 2021 supondrá una
oportunidad para avanzar en este aspecto
otro reto es el acceso al empleo ya que
las mujeres afrodescendientes se
enfrentan más obstáculos para acceder a
puestos de trabajo a pesar de su
preparación costarrica recién aprobó una
ley de acciones afirmativas que
establece que el 7 por ciento de las
plazas vacantes en entidades públicas
serán asignadas a esta población siempre
que cumplan los requisitos y para apoyar
al progreso en particular de las mujeres
afrodescendientes el instituto de
mujeres incluirá acciones afirmativas de
participación política e independencia
económica y acceso a la salud
[Música]